Hallo ihr Lieben, wir machen heute dieses Charcuterie Board und falls ihr euch wundert warum meine
Nase so ein bisschen gewachsen ist, ich werde
gleich nochmal den Hamza damit pranken, aber es
riecht so schlimm da drin, dass ich sie jetzt mal ganz
kurz wieder abnehme. Wir machen dieses
heftige Halloween Charcuterie Board. Für alle, die es noch nicht gehört haben und ich
habe es auch erst vor ein paar Monaten das erste
mal gesehen, dass es so etwas gibt. Ich habe auch
schon mal eins gemacht, als meine Freundinnen da waren,
das kann ich euch gerne mal einblenden. Das war dann
eher viel, viel kleiner und es waren ganz andere
Sachen drauf. Das coole ist, so ein Board ist
eine neue Abwandlung von einem Fingerfoodbuffet.
Man hat alles eng beieinander auf einem Board, oder
auf einem großen Teller, und das kann sowohl süß,
als auch herzhaft sein. Ich hab das auch genau so
gemacht. Hier sind Süße Sachen, dort Herzhafte.
Das coole ist, jeder kann sich einfach
bedienen und das nehmen, was man möchte und ich
persönlich finde auch es ist alles ein bisschen
einfacher. Man kann es einfacher gestalten, als
so ein Fingerfood Buffet, weil dann hat man ja
bei einem Butter alles so einzeln
stehen. Reih an Reih und so weiter und da muss man
halt immer so viel auch selbst machen, damit das
nach etwas aussieht. Hier habe ich aber auch
viele fertige Sachen schon und die Kunst ist es
einfach das alles ansehnlich zu präsentieren.
Aber ich habe auch vieles selbst gemacht und das
zeige ich euch jetzt mal im Schnelldurchlauf.
Ich starte mit diesen Mumienwürstchen
und dafür habe ich mir einfach tiefgekühlten
Blätterteig aufgetaut, circa zehn Minuten, dann
in feine Streifen geschnitten und einmal um die
Würstchen herum gewickelt. Das ganze dann bei 220
Grad Ober- und Unterhitze, für so circa 18 bis 22
Minuten, bis sie goldbraun werde, in dem Backofen
gegeben und anschließend einfach die Augen
noch drauf machen, aber das machen wir dann noch nachher.
Danach habe ich diese Windbeutelmonster gemacht
und dafür ganz einfach Zartbitterkuvertüre fein
hacken ( ich habe es in die Mikrowelle gegeben
600 Watt, also nicht so hoch stellen, und hat es
ungefähr 2,5 Minuten gedauert), immer wieder
umrühren und sobald die Kuvertüre geschmolzen ist,
die Windbeutel rein geben und das Ganze auf
dem Backpapier geben und da könnt ihr dann Augen
dazugeben, gerne ungleichmäßig... Mal 4, mal 5...
Ein paar Streusel und dann sind sie auch schon fertig.
Bretzel gehören für mich sowieso auf das  Charcuterie Board, habe ich auch direkt eingekauft, aber
ich fand sie so ein bisschen langweilig und
habe dann einfach nur Cake Drip in verschiedenen
Farben genommen und quasi einfach drauf gedrizzelt.
Damit es einfach so ein bisschen hübscher aussieht.
Dür diese Geister habe ich Eti Puff genommen. Ich
weiß die Türken unter euch kennen sie jetzt
wahrscheinlich. Da ist dieser Schaumstoff mit dem
Keks dran und da einfach nur ein Gesicht
aufzeichnen. Ich habe dafür meinen schwarzen
Cake Drip verwendet. Dann habe ich hier noch so
Babybel Kürbisgesichter. Dafür nehmtihr
euch einfach ein sehr scharfes Messer
oder Skalpell und schnitzt das ganz
einfach ein.Das geht so schnell.
Jetzt geht es ans Eingemachte. Endlich :)
Ich habe mir hier so ein Board geholt. Ist
schon ziemlich groß. Das ist eigentlich ein Board, was ich für Foodfotos benutzte.
Wir können natürlich auch kleinere benutzen oder
wenn eine Riesen-Party ansteht, dann verteilt
es gerne komplett auf den Tisch. Ich fange
jetzt einfach mal an, das Ganze so ein bisschen
zu drapieren. Darum geht es ja im Endeffekt.
Wie ich gerade schon erklärt hab, ihr könnt
euch jetzt überlegen mischt ihr süß und herzhaft
komplett, macht in einer Ecke nur süß in einer
nur Herzhaft. Ich würde sagen, ich gucke
einfach mal nach Gefühl. Ich starte mit
was Großem, da nehm ich zuallererst zum Beispiel...
Bin überfordert von der Auswahl geradexD
Dann nehm ich zuallererst Chips, denn die haben
viel Volumen. Die nehmen schon
ganz viel vom Board ein und deswegen fang ich
damit an. Das sind so Wasabi Chips in
Grün, deswegen habe ich hauptsächlich gekauft.
So jetzt kommen die Tuc Kekse (Cracker), also diese
ganzen Cracker etc. funktionieren sehr
gut. Kleiner fun fact: Diese Cracker in sour
cream & onion... ich war damals vor zehn
Jahren bei der Marktforschung mit dabei, da
existiert irgendwo noch ein Video von mirxD
endlich das probiert es nun gar nicht auf dem
markt war und ich fand es damals schon lecker
Ich fand es damals schon sehr lecker.
Jetzt in Schlangenlinien drapieren und das
finde ich macht es schon mal so richtig aus.
jetzt kommen die Würstchen zum Einsatz so, hier sind
meine Würstchen und da ich jetzt so viel ab jetzt
zwölf Stück insgesamt. Kann ich sowohl in der
einen ecke, als auch zwischendrin noch welche
mit verbauen ich packe es hier neben den topten
ein paar hin und den fehlen übrigens noch augen
das mache ich jetzt direkt da könnte entweder
zucker augen nehmen fast immer nicht ganz so
oder ihnen einfach um even scheiben ich bin
zu dem entschluss gekommen dass oliven doch
nicht so gut aussehe weil die sind sehr groß
daher nehme ich jetzt doch zucker augen ist so
fragwürdige kombi aber es ist ja auch halloween
da gibt nämlich einfach ein bisschen ketchup als
kleber und gibt es zwei zucker augen ich habe ja
auch extra platz dafür gelassen quasi in die mitte
so jetzt die oliven was zur liebe natürlich
auch immer ganz gut passt sie mit verschiedene
käsesorten da habe ich kam an der ich habe
weichkäse hartkäse da hab ich eigentlich alle
möglichen varianten geholter käse ist ja auch
so wenn man erwachsen ist ich fühle mich noch
nicht so erwachsen aber wenn man erwachsen ist
übrigens auch ein dessert wusstet ihr dass so die
oliven habe ich jetzt hier da bieten sich so diese
sorten an die ihr dann auch seine stück bekommen
also ich hier zum beispiel und dann kann man
einfach wie beim kuchen so stück herausschneiden
und jetzt solltet ihr auch immer so ein bisschen
darauf achten dass sie so ein farbspiel habt also
nicht sehr viel brown auf einer stelle nicht ganz
viel weiß immer so sondern nehme sie die babywelt
und packte hier schon mal direkt dazwischen und
dieser farbklecks wirkt schon wieder richtig auch
richtig band wollte ich noch etwas sagen aber
das wirkt so ist sie halt interessanter aus
wenn ihr viele verschiedene farben miteinander
kombiniert so typisch für halloween sind diese
kürbisse und da habe ich mir überlegt nehme
ich jetzt einfach ein bisschen popcorn ich
habe jetzt hier oben am und nicht so eine große
öffnung aber ich kann ihn ja hier einfach relativ
mittig drapieren und hinten raus das popcorn
raus laufen lassen was haben wir denn hier die
profi cacau und trocken sein wir sind ja auch
ein bisschen dunkler noch nicht ganz so weit
zwischendurch müssen auch mal essen und zum
probieren das ist auch gut schnee von gestern
als nächstes habe ich hier rinder salami dann
nehmt euch einfach so eine scheibe einmal hier
so in der hälfte und dann nochmal knicken und
dann macht er immer so weiter und wichtig ist
dass ihr dann nicht so die gleiche richtung
nimmt sondern in dem gegen gesetzte richtung
so ein bisschen drapiert dann habt ihr nämlich
schon mal so eine richtig richtig schöne linie
und da könnt ihr auch so ein richtig schön
lange strang ziehen ich bleibe hier oben
in der sehr herzhaften ecke wort die würstchen
sind und genau liegt das dann einfach so dahin
also solange sachen wie zum beispiel jetzt
hier immer diese die strings jetzt kind
geliebt und diese snack werden die passen
auch mal ganz gut die könnte schön an den
rändern drapieren wie oft hab ich das wort
therapieren gesagt in diesem video das ist
die süße ecke die kommen ja die pack ich
hierhin und jetzt kommen natürlich die
sache nicht vorbereitet habe gleich noch
trauben und die sachen nicht vorbereitet
habe die praktisch alle zehn die süße ecke also
einmal diese windbeutel monster dann merkt man
auch okay da wird es langsam süß die brezeln und
anschließend einfach nur noch die lücken füllen
es muss richtig voll aussehen es darf nicht
so rüberkommen als er hätte man nicht genug
genug sachen da gehabt daher die lücken noch
mal füllen mit müssen da könnte der wahlliste
nehmen oder cashewkerne oder diese umwandelten
und einfach alles was sie nur so finden könnt
wird heftig aus
doch das schreckt mich jetzt
ein super das war zu viel sagt
okay war ist es riecht so dass plastik aber ganz
und gar hansa wie findest du es was wir bloß ein
eindruck heftig heftig hektar man in so ein spiel
haben mit freunden okay vielleicht auch einige
nennen so ist das wahrscheinlich schon so 678
personen zehn personen dann also zehn personen
ist eugen ja als erstes weg koller films ja auch
eher so dass du zum snacken gedacht das kann ich
jetzt ist was du jetzt geht alles andere ist ja
verkauft also muss ich so sagen was du weißt was
ich niemals essen würde ist das hier gemachten
käse käse ich mache was ich auch gemacht aber
das rezept sehen wenn diese monster gemacht da
sind einfach das sind tiefgekühlte windbeutel das
ist dann vorerst nur der name sozialen david
villa sondern aus geschichten cool ich habe
das jetzt wollte ich bin froh wie bei extrem ja
sonst und ich hab ich habe ich überwunden die zu
kaufen ja das war schon okay ich will es jetzt
versprochen hallo rudi schrift es so wie heute
uns etwas süßes geben dürft ihr gerne weiterleben
oha also kann als jurist arbeiten würden ja dann
hast du ich könnte mir jetzt mal ein bisschen
was haben wir denn hier schön dass ein cracker
cottbus einfach so überall hin greifen wo man
gerade lust hat ich find's cool ich war ja dann
später sagen wann fängt er mit herz sondern
das ist schon in den ferien ja dann will ich
mal sagen ich hoffe das video durchgefallen
ist man ein ganz anderes videos bringen noch
ein zusatz video dieser woche und in nächster
zeit gibt es auch mal drei videos die woche von
uns ich wünsche euch es noch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen bis zum nächsten doch zu sagen du sowas